this is a production of cornell
university
yep i'm in uh rebecca nelson's lab and
today i'm going to be talking to you all
about
exploring the genetic basis of fusarium
ear rot resistance
and field component traits so i just
want to
direct your attention to this nasty
looking ear on the left
and these white streaks that are on the
on the kernels
and those are signs of fusarium ear rot
this is a disease caused by a fungal
pathogen fusarium verticillioids
it can infect the ear by a few different
methods
either by systemic affection or more
commonly
via the silk channels or injury to the
ear most commonly
due to insects and if you serum ear rot
we saw those sort of streaked
starburst symptoms that are signs of the
fungus
on the kernels and
it can have a yield penalty just by
you know being an ear rot but more
concerningly
is that the fungus also produces these
fumonos and mycotoxins
now these mycotoxins affect human and
livestock health
they're regulated uh in the united
states uh this is the range for human
consumption
and this uh females in b1 is the most
toxic form
it sort of resembles uh lipid and
affects lipid synthesis
um and so there's uh because of this
regulation there can be an economic cost
if a grower has
corn that's over these limits now these
are
most commonly found in uh tropical and
subtropical climates
uh much warmer than we have around here
um
so most of the work i'll be talking
about today or all of the work actually
was performed in north carolina and it
is a significant disease in
southern united states corn production
however i think maybe within my lifetime
we'll be doing
some fusion eret trials here in new york
as well
now this disease has been kind of worked
on in our lab for about the past 10
years
and in particular a past grad student
laura morales was really interested in
looking at
how this disease related to different
ear traits or
yield component traits so
to kind of set the scene laura had
looked at
within the goodman diversity panel
and found that in the temperate
subpopulation these yield component
traits shown here clustered here
uh did not correlate with fusion ear rot
however if you analyze the tropical
subpopulation
they're actually positively correlated
indicating that perhaps if you're using
tropical germplasm
breeding for increased yield might also
increase susceptibility to ear rot
and vice versa if you breed for uh
resistance you might
uh affect yield so that's
a little concerning and uh laura looked
deeper into this
in a 2019 paper where she
used nam families to identify some
qtl and this is a busy table but i just
want to highlight
those in blue or qtl that
she found affected both fusarium ear
erot resistance
as well as ear traits while those here
in orangish
are those that were specific to fusarium
ear rot resistance
so she found many qtl and i've just
highlighted a few here that i'll be
talking about more later
so this was sort of the platform for me
to uh
take off from some of her work and try
to really have the goal of
better understanding how fusarium era
and these yield component traits are
controlled within loci
um are there is plyo trophy occurring
or is it all linkage of different genes
um
and also do we have this sort of only
have this
uh serum era ear trade trade-off
or can you have sort of a double win
scenario
and then are there different dynamics
going on in tropical
versus temperate germplasm so
really the basis of my work has been
using this nested
near isogenic line population it's
developed about like 15 years ago or so
by syngenta and you can now acquire seed
from a cement
and what's nice is that this nil
population
was developed using b73 as their current
parent
and 18 of the namm founders as the donor
parents
we acquired our lab acquired these nils
in two separate sets
and so they've been those two sets have
been analyzed by
uh judy kolkman for northern leaf flight
and she found
some nice uh results for uh
loci that are affecting mlb resistance
and laura also has a paper looking at
the separate set
for southern leaf blight resistance so
both foliar diseases
but we've now been able to sort of unify
all of these together
and what i'll be talking about today
will be the first time we've been using
it on
an ear rot disease
so to give you a sense of what this sort
of mill germplasm looks like across the
genome
i'm showing here the introgression
tiling path
for about 10 of them that
are included in the experiment i'm going
to be talking about today
here on the y-axis each tick mark is
just a different nil
um couldn't include the names uh because
if there's so many
and then the blue lines are the donor
introductions which
within each of those nils and so all the
white space is just representing your
b73 recurrent parent and so you can see
that even
with just 10 percent of our total mil
population we can get pretty good
coverage of the entire
genome
now i wanted to build off of laura's
work and so
um for my experiment i selected mills
that were
had introductions within the qtl that
she had previously identified
that i showed earlier in that table here
the blue
uh bluish uh highlight represents those
trade off
qtl that have affect both fer
and different ear traits whereas these
orangish bases qtl
are those that affect just fer
now to zoom on zoom in on just one of
those
uh we can still see that this chromosome
one
qtl here that laura identified
sort of in orange here has nine
nils with introductions that are
contained within it
um and what's
where you're trying to see is whether
these nils actually contain
the variation that she had observed and
can we
sort of uh validate uh her qtl effect as
well as try to
um we have more donors
in this population and try to see if we
can understand more about
the genetic control of that locus
so our experimental design was to grow
all of our nils
out here in beautiful clayton north
carolina
um inoculate them with serious silio
ladies
and as i mentioned earlier there were
196 mills in this experiment along with
their founder parents and not all of
those were
included in were from my experiment per
se
also miriam maoun a former postdoc in
our lab and our lab manager isrepka also
had mills
in this experiment so some of the
results i'm showing you are
representing uh mills that they had
included in their experiments as well
but they were all grown together under
the same conditions and same treatment
in four plots inoculated plots and three
ears were harvested per plot for
phenotyping
so for phenotyping we just took some
visual estimates
for disease and insect damage
and we also utilized this flatbed
scanner pipeline
developed by nathan miller at the
university of wisconsin
and so you can see an image from that
here you get nice cob length and
cob width measurements as well as you
can get mesh metrics of cob color
and we took some other yield component
traits and we're actually still working
through some of this stuff to get
their mycotoxin data as well as to get
scanned kernel traits
now i've taken a couple different
approaches to try and analyze this data
one is a pretty basic one to just look
at within a qtl
so for example within this chromosome
one qtl i showed you before
seeing whether we can just fit an anova
model to see whether
there's variation among those nils
for that trait another is to take a more
genome-wide
approach and using all of our phenotype
run association mapping uh for
each of the traits
so slightly uh discouragingly uh
this within qtl analysis using anovas to
look for
variation within each of the traits that
laura had previously found
did not find any significant
differences so that was slightly
discouraging
but looking at genome-wide also for
fusion
era it was slightly frustrating to not
find significant
results for this however
when looking at some of our yield
component traits
uh we did find significant hits for cob
length on our geos
here a couple on chromosome one as well
as chromosomes eight and ten
and i particularly want to note here on
uh
chromosome 1 around 50 megabase pairs
we also found a hit for this cobb red
intensity tree and
this cobb color is a trait that's
actually
has some major effect loci uh unlike
um sort of fusarium era which is all
quantitative
um as well as many of the
sort of gear traits cob length for
example
and so here we can see we have some nice
peaks uh
that indicate we have some variation in
our population controlling
sort of some of these contrasts that i'm
showing up here
in cobb color and when you
look at some major effect loci you can
see that
we can identify
some co-localization between many of
these cloned
major effect genes and our
guess peaks here and i particularly want
to highlight pericarp
color 1 which is
previously been shown to be involved in
fumonosyn resistance
so i found it interesting that uh
this region seems to be although we
didn't have variation in fusion erot
we do have uh a hit for it
possibly a gene that's involved in uh
humanitarian resistance as well
so to summarize uh our scanner
phenotyping and that pipeline
along with their near isogenic lines
provide a rich data set to explore these
sorts of issues sort of our preliminary
within qtl analysis hasn't yielded much
but association mapping did find some
significant loci
that are promising and i'm interested in
following up on
and hopefully more to come as
phenotyping
and analysis progresses i want to
finish by thanking everyone in the
nelson lab especially
those bolded who contributed a lot to
this work
as well as our collaborators at north
carolina state
who helped us with field space and
inoculations
funding sources and of course thanks to
all the
beautiful corn that had to suffer for
this experiment
so thanks for listening and i'm happy to
take questions
sure um that's a clap too um
good job will um so it looks like your
nil 1194 has a relatively narrow region
when you tile it with the other
nils in your qtl region do you have an
idea of how many
genes are in that narrow region that you
could look for candidates
um i don't and
i guess there's also the concern that it
might not
contain the you know i i don't know
where in that qtl
the genes controlling these uh
phenotypes
are so it could be actually not even in
that intragression
at all um but
yeah not sure how many um genes are in
there
and not even sure if the genes were
interested or even contained in that
introduction
so to follow up with that would it be
worth you know what the nam parent is
for that
in aggression line so would it be worth
going to the nam rails
and just inoculating them and seeing if
you could replicate that
that qtl region by mapping
yeah so this was um that's how that's
laura had used the nam rails to
initially identify these qtl so that's
sort of what we're
working off of
i guess that's sort of already been done
not not in all of the families though i
will say that
so we we're including more
donor parents in our our study
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu